next up the house of monogamy
now the reasons behind the savage's most
primitive practice remain a mystery
but we do know that monogamy is an
important tradition which allows the
savages to combine the core values of
their culture
ownership competition jealousy and
strife and here we are we do hope you
enjoy the presentation
for those of you continuing on to the
house of consequence we'd like to remind
you to please
what's the house of consequences it's
called the prison
yeah the cut off part of their social
body and keep it there
or even triple their body mass with a
consumption of food
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
burn it counselor burn of marks
yes
i thought you weren't coming till
tomorrow so forgive me who are you
cortez i administer the park surely the
director told you about me
oh um no
but he can be forgetful can he
i suppose he can yes he sent me to
administer the park for one year
seven years ago
[Laughter]
well i hope you enjoy your stay oh thank
you very much
[Music]
[Music]
uh i am going to miss it are you leaving
he didn't tell you tell me what
oh it's time do come and find me after
the show i'd love to give you a talk
personally
sorry excuse me
[Music]
nina is this part of it
um please just
that i've known
the sweet contentment
that i find with you
every time every time
you